let's bring in Acting Homeland Security
Secretary Chad Wolfe and just a quick
note I can hear the control-room if you
could maybe mute my mic there secretary
well thank you so much for joining us
today that there's a lot that has to
happen in order to get all of this
protective gear all across the country
to all of these hospitals and still
these hospitals are saying that we they
don't have enough can you tell me where
you think you are in terms of trying to
meet that demand
absolutely and thanks for having me on
this afternoon so FEMA along with DoD
personnel are really energizing the
supply chain and we've talked about an
air bridge and those are flights from
Asia working with those medical
manufacturers making sure that that
information or sorry that those supplies
get to the US and in a matter of hours
versus 32:37 days where they would
normally come on a maritime cargo ship
so we're trying to energize the existing
supply chain we're routing PPE equipment
to hotspots around the country at the
county level which is very important and
we're energizing that supply chain so
that other medical distributors district
distributions can continue to flow that
information to those hospitals to those
nursing homes and other areas that they
normally send their their PPE in those
supplies too so we're trying to confront
this a number of different ways and
right now it's working we're flying in I
think we've had 19 flights from Asia we
have another 52 planned so again we're
really trying to push as much PPE into
the system as possible I was thinking
about the role that FEMA has played in
trying to help people and all sorts of
different things including when I was
there at the White House there was
obviously several of them on natural
disasters mainly but those are often
localized events right so maybe FEMA
helps in like a four-state area and this
is a national crisis and I wonder what
you have found the pressure points are
on FEMA and maybe what else you might
need from Congress in order to help try
to get that done well Dana I think
you're exactly right FEMA is used to
responding to both natural and man-made
disasters but as you indicated they're
usually very localized so you have a
number of states they're working with
here we have all 50 states
all territories that are at a category 5
or a category 4 hurricane in most
instances in the type of level and
support that they need and so it's
really is an unprecedented situation
that that FEMA is confronting when we
talk about supplies or the supply chain
that is a private sector industry in so
FEMA again working through DoD and some
of the assets that they bring have
really gone above and beyond really
trying to get a handle and an insight of
how that information flows in that
private supply chain Network so that
they can track that those materials to
those hotspots and redirect them and of
course as you mentioned we continue to
get support from Congress the funding
that they provided not only FEMA but
other elements of the department and the
US government such as HHS is helping in
this fight we'll continue to evaluate
the resources that we need but we are
putting to put in to use the resources
that they've given us thus far and will
continue to push testing supplies PPE to
those hotspots areas and continue to
look at those other areas as you
mentioned that the top of your showed
Detroit Michigan Louisiana other areas
that we want to address before they
become a hot spot yeah I wonder if like
when you wake woke up this morning on
your to-do list or like the thing that
you're most worried about what was that
well from Department of Homeland
Security perspective we need to make
sure that we are is on the ball
regarding kovat and responding to this
I'm always also very concerned making
sure that we continue to do our
traditional counterterrorism mission at
the Department our adversaries whether
it's from a cyber perspective or just
the nation-state perspective are still
hard at work and so I want to make sure
that our capabilities are not degraded
or we're not missing the larger picture
as we respond to kovat we have a number
of entities within the department
responding FEMA Coast Guard CBP a lot of
folks doing a lot of good work but we
also need to make sure that we continue
to make sure that our adversaries aren't
trying to to test us and protect us
maybe one last thing you're also trying
to alert people that there are a
to defraud people there are that are out
there what would you like to say to
Americans that are tuning in today about
what they should be aware of online is
in particular yeah I think what we've
seen unfortunately is any crisis there
are bad actors out there that will try
to take advantage of individuals so from
a CBP our Customs and Border Protection
perspective imports and exports we see
fake or fraudulent protective equipment
trying to come in and go out of the
country we're certainly identifying that
and seizing that from an ice perspective
Homeland Security Investigations we're
looking at investigating criminal
networks who are also trying to prey on
the American people cyber crimes
internet scams the gamut we see bad
people trying to take advantage of the
American people here and so I guess for
the your viewers out there understand
the Department of Homeland Security is
on it we're we're doing our job every
day in conjunction with the Department
of Justice to make sure that we identify
we investigate and we disrupt these
attempts to either defraud the American
people or in worst cases provide
equipment that is that is very dangerous
absolutely all right secretary Chad well
if we appreciate it and we'll let you go
back to work thank you